for three hours today
president Donald Trump in Russian
President Vladimir Putin met at his
summit in Helsinki and though the
meetings now in the history books the
fallout and the political tax have just
begun now so much of the commentary
today was devoid of even the slightest
hint of context or history so we thought
would try to rectify that tonight he was
following a strategy that he's used
effectively with Xi Jinping of China in
kim jeong-hoon of north korea and the
president of course was gracious and
chummy with Vladimir Putin today
President Trump prefers to turn on the
charm in person while using the hammer
and sickle behind the scenes but the
president made his objective clear he
was there to begin a true reset of our
relationship with Russia cooperation
between our two countries has the
potential to save hundreds of thousands
of lives we have 90 percent of nuclear
power between the two countries as
president I cannot make decisions on
foreign policy in a futile effort to
appease partisan critics or the media or
Democrats who want to do nothing but
resist and obstruct I would rather take
a political risk in pursuit of peace
than to risk peace in pursuit of
politics I think that was my favorite
line of today well written the two
leaders did hit on a range of key issues
we also discussed one of the most
critical challenges facing humanity
nuclear proliferation discuss the
scourge of radical Islamic terrorism
addressed directly with President Putin
the issue of Russian interference in our
elections spent a great deal of time
talking about it and indeed it was on
that subject of Russian interference in
our election where the president gave
kind of a verbal gift to his critics my
people came to me dan coates came to me
and some others they said they think
it's Russia
I have President Putin
he just said it's not Russia I will say
this I don't see any reason why it would
be I have great confidence in my
intelligence people but I will tell you
that President Putin was extremely
strong and powerful in his denial today
don't use the word strong and powerful
immediately following the presser though
you would have thought that Trump
actually had defected to Russia given
the mass hysteria you have been watching
perhaps one of the most disgraceful
performances by an American president
he's with someone you know like Putin
who is a thug that world-class thug that
he sides with him again and again
against his own country's interest you
have the president the leader of the
free world taking the word of a Vladimir
Putin who from all accounts inside the
US government the US intelligence
community the law enforcement community
attacked American democracy in 2016 they
came across as mates on a soccer field
you should call this the surrender
summit surrender now did I miss
something today did Donald Trump
withdraw US sanctions on Russia or did
he invite back those 60 diplomats and
others he expelled in March from Russia
did he cancel future sales of lethal
weapons to Ukraine of course he didn't
but he met as well have given the media
and liberal hyperbole on what happened
today today Obama's CIA director John
Brennan tweeted in part Donald Trump's
press conference performance in Helsinki
rises and exceeds the threshold of high
crimes and misdemeanors it was nothing
short of treasonous and how does it
laugh about that and why did no one call
it surrender by the way when in 2009
President Obama nixed the European
missile defense shield that was to be
built in Poland is that a surrender to
Putin or was it a surrender or collusion
when Obama asked Russian Prime Minister
Dmitry Medvedev for a little favor until
the 2012 election was over
[Music]
they're holding hands there the public
spooning what was that a profiling
patriotism and I don't recall the media
kicking up any fuss when Obama joined
Cuban dictator Raul Castro for a
baseball game or normalized relations
with that murderous regime by the way a
puppet of Russia now you can also say
this Trump clearly should not have
created any semblance of moral
equivalency between our Intel community
even if it has its flaws which it does
and the assurances of Vladimir Putin as
the recent indictment of Russian agents
alleged there was meddling in the
election bipartisan members of
congressional panels concluded that so
did our Director of National
Intelligence but it also no sense that
it affected the outcome of the 2016
election and no Americans were named in
last week's indictment so president
Trump probably should have said it that
way said it that said that redressed it
that way instead he kind of committed an
unforced error but look the president is
right at the same time to be frustrated
by the envel that the deep state has
hung around his neck for two years now
first the elements within the FBI Lisa
Paige and Peter struck and now Muller
and his ever-expanding team and we know
inside the DOJ they basically protected
Hillary Clinton while attempting to dam
and undermine the legitimacy of Trump
selection and this Naz at the President
and it perhaps explains why he let those
wounds get the better of him today but
it is a good thing to improve our
relationship with Russia at the same
time we cannot appear to by their
obvious deception while we're standing
on the world say stage you know I'm
doing a lot of while at the same times
but this is a complicated thing and I
think while insulting Putin on camera
like doing that like dr. Donald Trump
versus Vladimir Putin and a total insult
fest
that wouldn't have accomplished anything
at the same time there are other subtler
ways to make our concerns in our
objections known and the president
should have taken that path u.s.
National Intelligence director Dan coats
issued a statement in the wake of the
summit today he said the following we've
been clear in our assessments of Russian
meddling in the 2016 election and their
ongoing pervasive efforts to undermine
our democracy and will continue to
provide unvarnished and objective
intelligence in support of our national
security now setting aside the overly
dramatic reactions and even the
presidents at times poor or an
unfortunate word choice let's look for a
moment at what Trump is substantively
doing visa vie Russia he's building up
the US military key at a NATO summit he
called out the German Russian Nord
Stream gas pipeline that scheme
Nordstrom - in March of this year he
imposed sanctions on five Russian
entities and 19 individuals for
interfering in the 2016 election
the media don't like to remind you of
that one of course that doesn't fit
their narrative and of course he closed
the Russian consulate in Seattle and as
I alluded to earlier he expelled Russian
diplomats and suspected spies 60 of them
so if Trump is Putin's poodle he has a
really odd way of showing it as Walter
Russell Mead wrote in American interest
last year if Trump really was a Russian
mole he would be doing things like the
following limiting fracking as much as
possible blocking oil and gas pipelines
cutting US military spending and trying
to tamp down tensions with Russia's Ally
Iran but trust doin know that
so the Selective indignation on the left
is truly hilarious they keep changing
their stories for decades they favored a
conciliatory stance first toward the
Soviet Union then toward the Russian
Federation and now they're all
pretending to care
Russia and casting Trump as a Putin
surrogate but it's good to remember just
a few years ago how certain liberals
reacted when then presidential candidate
Mitt Romney suggested that Russia was a
foe the 1980s are now calling to ask for
their foreign policy back because you
know the Cold War has been over for 20
years in many of the areas where we are
working to solve problems Russia has
been an ally Governor Romney's answer I
thought was incredibly revealing he acts
like he thinks the Cold War still on
Russia is still our major adversary I
don't know where he's been Mitt Romney
talks like he's only seen Russia by
watching rocky for so which is it should
we be getting closer to Russia and Putin
or should we have a dynamic of constant
confrontation and hostility the Liberals
change their views clearly depending on
which party has the White House I think
in the end what really matters is how
Trump handles the Russian relationship
going forward so despite some of these
verbal missteps the president has
already put us I think in a better
position by engaging Russia an opening
dialogue it's just a start and that's
the angle